let's return to our top story and the
afghan president ashraf ghani
having signed off now on the release of
400
taliban prisoners leading the way to
long-term
prospective peace talks with the
government and with the taliban
in the days ahead joining me now is
mushdaq raheem founding member of
afghanistan's
affairs unit an afghan think tank joins
me now from kabul good to have you with
us on the program
so the president has signed off on
releasing these 400 taliban
prisoners is that now the only obstacle
to sit down
talks between them and the government
well yes uh now that was the only hurdle
between the
uh between the agreement that was signed
between taliban and the americans and
the start of intro on talks that's the
most important part of the peace process
and i think that hurdle has now been
removed uh by the loya
decision where they have uh agreed
to release 400 prisoners that was the
bone of content
contention between the african
government and the taliban
and that was uh stopping both sides to
engage in the intravent talks
how much pressure was anna shrafghani or
how much was
how much pressure has he been under to
agree because he
has often said that he felt that his
government wasn't included
in the initial talks and the agreement
that was signed between the u.s and the
taliban back in february
well yes he was under pressure because
uh
from one side he was faced with the
legal hurdles for the release of 400
prisoners
uh there were serious uh issues around
those uh 400s
released from legal perspective but from
the other side uh
all the sides uh were uh putting
pressure on the government that
uh unless and until that release happens
the intraven talks were not going to
start so that's why everybody was
demanding release of those prisoners
so he was caught between a rock and a
hard place and
uh that's why one can say that he was
under pressure
but now that pressure has been released
thanks to the loya
indeed he he will sign in the coming
hours
that edict as such but is the ball now
partly in the taliban's court ghani is
proposing
a ceasefire will that happen
well not necessarily because the
agreement
was made that once the five thousand
prisoners are released the intra-avran
talks will begin
and during that the ceasefire will be
discussed but the expectation is that
a different uh mortise operandi that is
reduction in violence can be something
we pursued by both sides because
the taliban at least for the time being
cannot compromise their military
position and cannot
go into ceasefire mode just because they
want to maintain
their hold on the conflict context
and until they are sure of any
substantive progress
uh don't expect them to engage in a
ceasefire
so for the time being uh one can say
that instead of considering uh who holds
the ball
uh the the basic thing is that we are
all set for the entrepreneur which
should be a watershed
event in the current uh peace process
that's going to open the way
uh for for uh negotiation among avranz
in order to settle on future outlook
of the avran political setup uh agree
on uh giving up on the armed violence
and engaging in political processes and
indeed
in terms of engaging in political
processes the u.s needs this
certainly as a foreign policy success
ahead
of the u.s presidential election if it
does
uh seem that we are heading towards
inter afghan talks how much
of this will be used do you think in mr
in president trump's campaign to be
re-elected
well certainly he already has uh some
sort of
uh campaign material available to him in
terms of
an agreement on bringing the troops back
he has
the americans have already started troop
reduction in afghanistan
he can use that secondly the start of
introvert talks definitely gives him
further material more material to to
tell the american people that he has
been able to reach a stage
at least to give a chance to the peace
process and give a chance for full for
troops withdrawal from afghanistan
so definitely he's in a good position as
far as the afghan
conflict is concerned and he will be
able to cash it in
cash in on this during his campaign we
should see what happens for the moment
it's always good to get your input
mushtaq rahim joining us
from kabul thanks for your time